[musique]
Repo beaucoup d'insulaires un cou d'ici le samedi 11 mars
vers 20
L'envoi de l'unité 1 et de l'unité 2 ensemble prend 17 minutes dans une pièce séparée.
personnel de la coopérative agricole
J'étais à l'usine le jour du banquet
Tout d'abord, c'est petit après le passage des passants
Il y avait Matsunami à l'endroit où le tremblement de terre s'est produit
En raison de l'impact du tsunami
En raison de la perte de taxation, le pouvoir de façonner les 1ère et 2ème unités a été perdu.
C'est pourquoi je suis candidat à Matsushomai
Il est tombé, donc le son était plus fort que la dernière fois
Merci pour votre état
En service à l'époque
Je pensais que c'était un vrai troll alors j'ai utilisé une lampe de poche etc.
Quant au pistolet qui peut être confirmé, il est à portée de main
On dit qu'il a frappé autant de 86 que possible avec son équipement
Ouais
[musique]
Feuille de route de décembre dernier
Centrale nucléaire de Fukushima Daiichi
Il y a eu une révision de la feuille de route pour le démantèlement
Je l'ai mentionné plus tôt
Nous travaillerons sur des choses telles que la réduction supplémentaire de la production d'eau de source.
encore
Situé à l'intérieur de la cuve de confinement du réacteur
Nous procédons aux travaux de préparation pour sortir ces choses dans l'ordre.
je vais venir